[Music]
janine
is in abilene texas hi janine how are
you
hey i am so glad to hear your voice my
friend
and rachel gosh you guys are phenomenal
it's amazing to hear your ads and and
all the stuff that you offer
i've been watching you and listening to
you for a few years
i'm in a kind of a sad sac situation i
can say yippee i'm dead free
i'm totally debt-free but um i'm in a
situation where i'm farmer jeanine from
abilene but i got no money
and i'm 61 years old and i'm getting
ready
to sell out i'm dealing with the toxic
situation after my father's death
who was my farm partner
and um you know our tractor got
pulled off apart so
um my heart's not in it here anymore
and um what i make
from this place which looks like around
i don't know four hundred thousand
dollars
i'm gonna put into the next place i go
to and i think for about half of that
maybe just maybe i'll find someone who
has that love in their heart that
needs to move on somewhere else and i
can find some place
that i can still be the farmer still
make those grasses
and meadows and the love that god gave
us
and um walked forward from there but i'm
kind of trying to i'm i'm overwhelmed i
mean this is like a
20 somewhat year move it's part
industrial
part just personal and empty now i'm
going through my house i've i've done a
lot of the sad
sad things i've had to do the one thing
i got from my father's life was
a nasty note for my mother with a broken
hammer and a boat tied around it
and i'm still grateful for that hammer
you know um so what is it we can best
help you with today huh
well what i what i want to do you know
when i've i've been watching recently
uh financial peace uh cash flow planning
like i said i have no doubt everything's
paid for i have an old truck but it
works like a charm
you know i'll take good care of it and
everything i have here is paid for so my
thing is
how do i best protect my assets and make
that work for me walking forward because
what i'm going to do
is i'm going to try and find as much as
i love my church here that's
probably the only thing that i'll miss
right now
is that i just want to walk forward and
into a new community i've already kind
of figured out the direction
i want to go it was a really odd move to
say i have to move away from toxic
into something better and i figure about
half of that
is probably what i'm going to need to
make a new start and then that other
house
has to go into the rest of my life you
know let me
let me tell you let me tell you what i'm
hearing okay
yeah um
an amazing amount of the roots
of your life are all being pulled up at
once
oh yeah and there and the loss of your
dad
um
the loss of the dream that was you were
going to be on this farm
until yeah the heart of it the loss of
what should have been with family and
isn't
because they aren't and there's just a
whole lot of pain in your voice honey
and and that doesn't make you a bad
person that just means that's what's
happened
yeah and that just means you're human
and so um
yeah i think what's going to be really
important is for you to move
slowly in your future moves
uh and to give yourself some time to
heal because you're pulling this up by
the roots
yep and uh then you're gonna move it
over here and replant it and we gotta
make sure
it takes hold before we start going
crazy over here so i i want you to make
a bunch of big investment decisions
that are permanent i want you to move
slow and give yourself some room to cry
because if i were in your shoes and you
would
you've lost your your dad the dream of
the farm
everything that the farm represented the
connectivity to your church the
connectivity of the community
the toxic family members that shouldn't
have been but are
they're not filling their role properly
and so you're going to have to go over
here
and set some new relationships and as dr
john dolone talks about the way you
overcome trauma
is grief the way you overcome trauma is
community
and you you need a lot of room to grieve
before you start making a bunch of
investment decisions um
you're planning with a brain that's
foggy right now
and uh and that doesn't mean you're
inept it doesn't mean you're not capable
it means right now you are hurting a lot
that's what i'm hearing oh you can i
mean yeah i think everyone listening
right now can hear that in her voice and
the
there's an urgency to janine so i think
that the advice obviously to slow down
slow down it's gonna be really wise
because we do find people that are in
these big
transition periods that come from
tragedy
can make really poor financial decisions
again not because
you're unintelligent but because you're
literally just making these on the go
with
with a foggy brain so slowing down
um and then finding okay what is my
dream you said farming is something you
love so to have a goal
maybe in 24 months in 12 months
just slowly i'm okay if you don't buy a
farm and you don't do any investing for
a year and a half and you just move to
the new community
and just spend some time weeping spend
some time
building new friendships and new
community at your new church
spend some time getting to know the dirt
in the area before you buy dirt
spend some time slow down a little bit
give your toes give yourself a little
wiggle room here to where then when
you're telling the story it doesn't go
in circles
and that means you it means you know the
fog is lifted but we all tell stories in
circles when we're freaked
and um and we all have been there honey
we all know how you feel
so be praying for you